thank you this is a bill relative to
schools approved for a school tuition
program by a school board we all should
have a side by side there in front of
you which shows the house version and
the Senate version
and
just for discussion purposes I'm going
to hand this amendment out too to
everybody
I have a few extra copies right here
in case
anybody in the public may want to see
that
um
looking at that amended version
um there there's terminology which has
been struck
um
in the Senate version you have uh is a
public school designated as this as the
anchor School
uh this version right here is is a
public school or public Academy
complying with the provisions of 194 23e
that does not require additional tuition
um
the the question that I I've heard is
that this this hones us in a little bit
closer to the situations which we have
out there we have these schools which
are k4s k3s K through eights which don't
have the receiving
District levels for beyond what they
offer in their own community so their
tuition out there's a number of
districts which do this throughout the
state a large number do what they have
to do it and there are a number of
agreements and contracts which are
developed between the the sending
district and the receiving districts for
how the tuition payment all is going to
be paid for
um
the situation I I reflected on and I've
talked with is the situation in my
district I have two of them land aft and
Piermont both tuition out one's a k
through three one's a k through k
through eight
and the K through 8 does tuition their
kids to Thetford Academy and Vermont to
uh River
Oxbow High School which is over in
Bradford Vermont which is a regular
public high school in the state of
Vermont St Johnsbury Academy which is a
school much like Pinkerton Academy here
in in New Hampshire the tuition out the
Rivendell which is a Interstate School
District between Orford Vermont and New
Hampshire and and fairly Vermont and
also the Woodsville High School
the situation is that the district has
set a cap of nineteen thousand dollars
is what they're going to pay for
tuitioning their students but they have
students already attending these various
schools
and the school at one of those this one
of those receiving schools has now which
they're all approved schools has upped
their cat up their tuition beyond the
cap but students are already attending
that within families that school and
other students in that in those families
are not there yet they want to go and
have the same Transportation all so they
they with the cap they can't
and so the difference here is well can I
as a parent pay that difference or can
the district pay it I think the the
legislation that we have in front of us
allows that to occur the issue becomes
this uh we're putting in public school
or public Academy those are high schools
only
and we do have some K through threes and
K through four switch tuition out so the
reference to 193 9 194 23e or even
without even putting a reference of a
statutory reference it Deals Only what
so
if that if that Amendment were to try to
deal with this and this is different
than manifest education hardship and
best interest to the student that that
sectional law this is not a manifest
education Archer this is not in the best
interest this is a contracted service to
provide what that child is guaranteed by
our statutes to receive that adequate
opportunity for an adequate education
so it's a actually it's it's it's a
different section of law
now where do we go and how we how do we
help try to support these schools which
are trying to contract with to get these
kids the education they need there was
an estab in this in this amendment right
here to do that this would do it for
grades 9 through 12.
it wouldn't do it for any Elementary or
perhaps the center length so what 194
23e without having a copy of it in front
of me that's just high schools is that a
provision of Justice January in here it
says that's just high scores yeah you
can look it up and think okay that's an
older one but if that part of Statute
hasn't changed
um that that section of 194 21
22 23 references
high schools
because the references back to high
school but also says they must comply
and you know with the approval standards
of what a high school is so it I think
it makes sure that everybody receives
that opportunity to receive all those
Services if you go farther in 194 uh up
to 194 colon 27 I think then you start
getting into some other
um
areas which may include the the
elementary
so I guess the question is why are we
limiting it why wouldn't we just say
that at least one option is a public
school or public Academy that does not
require additional just strike complying
with the provisions of RSA and that
would allow grades K through 12 public
so taking all stature reference out well
again if you strike the words from
complying all the way to the RSA right
it just says that it would be at least
one option as a public school or a
public Academy that does not require
additional tuition payments from parents
and that we're not limiting it just to
high school we're limiting it to any
school where where a district may have
to contract out for whatever reason
um a child where there's no again if you
read the beginning portion of this this
bill that says where there's no public
school for a child's grade it does in a
resident District so I'm thinking of
um Hill this is a great example right so
the town of Hill has an elementary
school K through K through five but it
stops at five
and then they tuition out their kids to
other schools for Franklin or Newfound
for the for the I got that yeah so if we
didn't if we don't put that statutory
reference we just say that it would
allow them to create multiple contracts
in multiple schools and if one happens
to be more than base tuition it would
allow parents if they wanted to choose
it to pay the difference see the the
reason why I added the statutory
language into that is that Romans 6
is within the statute section of law
which deals with manifest education
so as Romans 6 referencing manifests
education
best interest is also there first you
know and I used to do that as a
principal when in the best interest of
student I sometimes moved one's kid from
uh Mr Tim's class to Mrs Ruth's class
across the hallway where learning
teaching styles were a little bit
different or there was not the the issue
that was occurring in the first
classroom that's the best interest by
the Manifest educational hardship is the
next step which you go into the realm of
dealing with the board and and you you
you have to have that particular
criteria which we have is something
that's severe and significant
an issue of some kind that's where this
is within and I was just wondering if if
would be only referencing manifest best
interest or would it be referencing that
the contract that you have to do for a
represent my own yeah and I I also I
also have a concern about uh that may
require parents to pay additional
tuition I mean the issue here is you
have a public school
and that uh
kids should be able to go to school
without they're already paying for it
through taxes Etc so why should parents
then have to pay additional seem to me
that if a school district identifies a
particular School District
then they ought to be they ought to pay
for that and the parents shouldn't have
to be have to pay a portion of it and
that's the concern that I have with this
but that that argument could be rebuffed
in a community too by saying that we we
were sending our kids to that school
when the tuition Camp was 19 000 the
school now has since up that Annie
and so when Johnny is now going to be a
junior the next year he's going to have
to pay you're going to have to pay that
difference should what happens if they
say no we're not going to pay above our
calf so if that student now have to pick
another school and move to another
learning environment in a high school
well it seem to be that in the contract
there'll be some kind of a grandfather
for that particular individual that
particular family that's involved in
that I think
I think that's what the designation of
the anchor school was that's what we
heard in committee was that you know the
anchor school would prevent the parent
from paying because it's the option
yeah but if I may I think the issue that
Rick is talking about though is is
beyond just the anchor School
that using your example of St John's for
example St John's Academy for St
Johnsbury where there'd be you would
indicate I think like a five thousand
dollar difference if I wanted to send I
wanted my child to go there rather than
to well it was between 500 and a
thousand dollar difference no no high
grants okay all right good okay
yeah so again if I remember and chairman
if you can remind me but again the
conversation we had was and the reason
why the Senate amended it was a we do
think there should be a no cost option
and that should be allowed and that's
what this uh the Senate Amendment does
it says yes you could go to a more
expensive school and pay the difference
but only if it's a parental choice and
the fact that you have a public school
option that costs you nothing that the
school's already contracted to so if you
want to just send your kid to school you
have a list of approved contracted
schools by the school board and you
could send them there as long as the
cost was equal to or less then but we
also want the ability to if a parent if
there was a reason to move to a
different school and it was a cost
differential and a parent wanted to do
that choice I'm going to use the example
of I'll go back to again Hill and say
that if they contracted with Franklin
and Newfound but the parent lives in
Tilton and wants to go to win Squam
instead so the school board it could
form a contract and if winter Squam is
more expensive and the parents still
wanted to go there they would just have
to pay the difference because it's their
choice to go there otherwise they can
choose the two school districts that
cost them nothing but they shouldn't be
given enough they shouldn't be obligated
to pay more unless they had no cost
option as well does that make sense so
that's what we tried to do in this bill
was to give that third option if a
parent wanted to that the school
district could at the the school
district could enter into a contract
with that was and then the parent if
they wanted to do that would have to pay
the difference yeah I understand that
but but the concern that I have is that
um let's say a parent wanted to send
using your example to win a Squam but
they can't afford to do that
they would have two other contractual
obligations two other public school
options that had no cost to them so
they've been given that choice but then
there's a differentiation of that of
what's available I mean there should be
some Equity as it relates to options for
kids even if the parent can't afford it
for those that can't afford it but want
to go to the same that same school
example it's it to me I just I just
don't think parents
should be able to go where they want to
go and the school district the Loke the
resident School District should pay for
that
yeah yes I'm just thinking the same
thing applies to when you send a child
to college you have a whole mess of
options and you pick probably the
college that you can't afford I don't
think you can go to the College of your
choice and say I like to go here but I
don't want to pay your tuition because I
can't afford it you pick something that
is fits within your finances
well and also when you're talking about
high school you you pick a high school
which fits your family's needs you may
work uh you know in a location where
there is one of those approved schools
and you can provide that transportation
to that school
and I think that in when I I look at of
the the small District that one of them
I have land app that is in fact the case
where one parent works over in profile
where profiles over towards Franconia
and the kids go to Lisbon for a high
school and there's also a tuition
program they have in place to go across
the river to St Johnsbury Academy
it depends upon which side of the
mountains you live on up there which way
and which roads go where and I think all
that's built around trying to meet the
needs of various regions Within These
communities that significant Geographic
differences like they do up there this
one yes
thank you Mr chairman uh
the towns I represent send
um I'll accept Newports send their high
school students somewhere else and it's
a combination of choice in Cornish and
area agreements in most of the other
schools and I think that's kind of what
we're bordering here when you talk about
an anchor school
I'm just cautious because there is no
definition of what an anchor school is
in the statute I think I get the idea
and I think it kind of conforms with the
area agreement but that's a different
kettle of fish that we I don't know if
you want to go into but we've always
seen high schools available in the Upper
Valley decades ago it was a problem
because schools didn't have room anymore
now the problem is that they they're
seeking students so we need to plan for
the future not just this case that's
going on right now there may not be a
room available in schools does the
school need an agreement that's that's
going to catch everybody or just are we
okay with schools being
a a one of many that you can choose for
yes Senator so again anchor schools the
interesting is again that's what we put
in our bill and we're quickly informed
it's actually no definition of anchor
School anywhere in our statute so we
have nothing and that's why we took it
out that's why this amendment I uh
chairman and I had a conversation we
took that out rather than go create a
definition that may cause a lot more
problems down the road the idea of just
Public Schools or public academies right
that you can transition to any public
school or any public Academy right but
the school had to have at least one
choice I was a public school or District
had to have at least one choice that was
free to parents right that there would
be no additional costs so that they
could have a
any sense an anchor school right a free
a cost that doesn't cost a parent any
additional monies so it's the reason why
we didn't stick with the in my
conversation with the chat I think uh
the chairman here also had conversation
representative Ladd about
um not keeping that phrase anchor school
because it doesn't exist in statute
anywhere and so we moved to just the
concept of making sure our district had
one public school that would for that
grade that would cost parents nothing
and there was there would be no
obligation for that parent to send their
child there but we also on the freedom
of it if a parent so chose again using
my example because I work in Tilton it's
easier for me to when I'm driving to
school to drop my kid off right in
Tilton rather than go the other
direction go to Newfound which is not in
the direction where I'm going to work so
I'm going to choose to go there but it
may cost me more money that's my choice
as a parent otherwise my obligation is I
got to take them the Newfound where
there's no cost
they make a follow-up comment yes I've
seen the choice
option work in Cornish because it
Cornish pays a cap if you want to go
with school that's cap or under great if
you want to go over you pay the
overpized nobody has a problem with it
it works very well it works for the town
some of the towns that have area
agreements uh parents are jealous
because they're really just stuck in one
option and uh and appreciate the freedom
that it gives the students in Cornish
you know in your District over there
were you talking about around Newport
and all they also had another school
which was tuition School uh Sunapee
and Sunapee uh was you know I think that
brings in part of the issue why we need
to do something because they were doing
something very different in terms of
[Music]
okay your neck of the woods yeah yes and
Croydon Croydon and Goshen and all that
up there and and and uh the the anchor
school was was Newport
and sanofi reserved the right to say
well we don't have this programming so
we can't take that particular student
um
so the show last thing so again I guess
I'm still just struggling why we want to
have that once one section of a sentence
in there that has comply with the
provisions of which limits at the high
school and why we wouldn't just strike
that from complying all the way to the
RSA that just says Academy that does not
require additional payment this allows
as I read through 193.3
um nothing in here talks about just high
school it's about all grades well I I
agree with you that we can have it
referencing that statute because that's
just a statute for high schools alone
and so I and I that was recognized after
this was put together so yeah if
if something were to go forward as I
would tend to support you know the
academy that does not require additional
you know from that on taking that
language out of the reference but then
the question is it's still Romans 6 but
it's underneath change of school or
assignment School tuition program
um
193.3
is that
the proper place for this
is where the statute is now yeah and
that's our interactions are so messed up
yeah so that's that's part of the
problem
Senator just a question I guess
um how would Transportation fit into
this in terms of if a child chooses a
different school who is a transportation
included in that cost or is the parent
I think if you look at 194
22 I think that's the sectional law
which they talk about the contract can
provide for that if the if the the
distance or transportation is needed
I think that that is also taken care by
you know the anchor is one of which I
know in the district I am transportation
is provided
to all those schools
except for Thetford Academy
and the St Johnsbury Academy for
Bradford for Woodsville for ribbon River
Rivendell it's all provided they link up
with that other district and they meet
buses get your kids get off get on
another bus
and go to school so
but also statutorily we're not required
by law to provide transportation
for 9 through 12.
we highly recommend that we we put that
in some of our finance law before but if
we're we're going to get rid of
the high school option and conclude this
for elementary as well and we statutory
required yes then we are
then we are
yes
but again I just remind everybody that
where this section of law already exists
yeah right we're not changing that at
all the only thing we're doing is saying
we're we're allowing that option of a
parent can choose a contracted School
outside of that costs more than the
minimum amount be able to pay that
because current law
is ambiguous at best so whether or not
it allows that or not and this clearly
clarifies that they can do that if there
is a cost but they have to have that
free option for any parent as well for
the people that choose not to so again I
I I don't want to get into the
transportation argument because that's
already covered underneath the set that
chapter the section six doesn't talk
about transportation in any way shape or
form so it there's some that that is in
some other section somewhere else oh
they were considering there's another
whether or not we want to allow parents
the right to pick a school that may cost
more and pay the difference or not
foreign
don't have a lot of experience in New
Hampshire but I do and others and I'm
wondering how those circumstances which
we discussed in committee one time
involving um
an involuntary if you will transfer
someone who's being abused or are
mistreated in one school needs to
transfer to the other and then do we
have the same questions as who pays what
does it cost I just don't understand how
that's handled and so I'm asking well in
the cases of uh like homelessness
mckinney-vento definitely takes care of
that excuse me takes care of that and
HHS if you're in if you get into abuse
and neglect so transportation is taking
care of those type of students
regardless we've had that up where I am
where we could only find living quarters
for some individuals down in Hanover but
the student was going to school in
Woodsville which is a good 45 minute
Ride Transportation was provided so this
the educational program wasn't disrupted
so it's obviously I'm okay with the
amendment striking as long as we strike
that one line to to deal with complying
all the way to the irsa I think that
again this allows parents some some
flexibility for if they know they've got
to go out of the town anyway because the
town doesn't have a grade that matches
their student this just gives them more
so further discuss should we just take a
moment and break by House and Senate and
see where we stand
are we talking about now just striking
out the exactly what the reference to
the RSA
and leaving designated as to Anchor
School in
okay
no no no no yeah no it's your your
Amendment which says which changes to
public school the public Academy then
striking complying with all the way to
the word that so okay lying with the
provisions of RSA blah blah blah strike
that those one two three four five six
yeah six words and leaving the rest and
that amendment I could support because
again we're keeping it to Public Schools
we're keeping it
um to all grades and just increasing
flexibility and options for New
Hampshire parents
okay
good to break for a second here
we'll go steal an office out there for
you
hey we're we're back right now and what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a break and we're going to ask that an
amendment be created uh based upon uh
the
laddling Amendment which we haven't
found is taking out the words complying
with the provisions of RSA 19424e
and we'll have that Amendment back and
we will take a break and we'll come back
uh following the next committee
conference
and and take action on on that amendment
that time so we're breaking right now
okay we have the next committee
conference coming up here and it's uh HP
536 is an act relative to the Charter
Public School joint legislative
oversight committee and relative to
Charter Public School use of unused
District facilities uh does everybody
so we have house and
um Senate versions the Senate version
adds on that second part of the title
and that's uh the portion that we will
be discussing right here today
um
uh Sarah Lang a senator Ward
the Senate version adds on use of these
uh Beacon schools for the purpose of you
know
Charter Public School
uh is there any objection to that
yeah I don't no no need to rehash this
but I am again immense light so yeah and
representative luno
sure I mean I would I would suggest
moving forward with the house position
which would be deleting the um
non-germaine Amendment
okay
yes so uh well Senator fan knows this uh
oh for the house side I'll explain why
this bill was brought it why this
amendment was brought in and why um we
adopted this
um so this originally was a bill that
was submitted by representative Hill
however OLS forgot to draft it so they
literally put put the request in they
acknowledged the request and then they
never drafted his bill and it wasn't
until January that he realized that it
never got drafted and so
um oh well I got the OLS from the
director showing that it was their fault
that they forgot to draft it so we added
as a non-dairain amendment to this bill
allow the bill to go forward but the
reason the bill was brought forward
originally was because this law is a
fairly new law that was put into play to
allow for the transition of public
school property from one Public School
entity to another Public School entity
going from a Traditional School to a
charter school in the original bill when
it was put in way back when that created
this law
um there was a timeline put into the
bill to allow for the to have the school
district respond and have the action
taken however somewhere in a committee
it was decided it wasn't needed and
therefore it was it was amended out of
the bill and just left to the language
that was there the problem is the first
time the law went to go to be used
um in and again it was in my district
when a Squam
um when a Squam downsized their campus
and ended up having a building on a
separate parcel of land that was free
and available and the charter school put
in an offer and it was completely
ignored by the school board for nine
months
um not acknowledged in any way shape or
form no negotiations happened nothing
happened
um and so that wasn't the intent of this
law the intent wasn't that to allow
school districts to ignore an offer put
in by a charter school and so this bill
came forward to require that school
boards act in some way shape or form and
start negotiations do something they
literally did not even meet with the
charter school for for nine months on
the offer or offer a counter offer or do
anything and so that's the reason why
this bill was brought forward was again
first through an AWS error second
because in in the first instance of the
law being used the timelines were
necessary in order to create some action
so that's why that's why we have the
amendment in front of us I think it's
it's reasonable I I want to remind
everybody that this is a transfer of
property from a public school entity to
a public school entity it's going from a
traditional school to a public charter
school so this isn't about private sale
to a private school this is about a
public school to a public school action
yes
thank you very much Mr a lot to unpack
there
um the um uh you know the errors happen
you know in operations so I don't think
that I don't think the fact that it
never happened necessarily justifies
um the um the subject matter of an
amendment but um but I want to I want to
start with what um uh Senator Lang just
just said no I want to be really really
clear
um a public chart charter schools are
public schools but they're not public
organizations they're private
organizations they're they're they are
operated under IRS code 501c3 uh
corporations it's a private Corporation
non-profit Corporation private not
public it's not run Charter Schools not
run by publicly elected boards they
don't have any um obligations back to
taxpayers
um
um they um they don't follow
um uh public
um
you know 91a laws they are private
organizations so so let's be absolutely
clear that the subject matter that this
amendment does is about selling public
property to a private organization the
private organization it's a charter
school but it's still a private
organization from the from a technical
standpoint
you know the other the other point I
think
um is worth um is worth making let me
just go back to it here is that um is
well actually it's more of a question
um how in the case of the the winner
Squam
um situation how did that turn out in
the end what happened
ultimately after not receiving any other
bids they'll end up moving forward with
the charter school but again it wasn't
until they waited and waited the way to
the charter school was trying to figure
out what it was doing
so again ultimately it ended up with the
charter school and the charter school is
buying it but the point is that they
were left in limbo for nine months and
they shouldn't have been right the law
was clear that
um they they have the right of the right
of uh of getting the unused facility but
the school district took no action when
we contacted the Attorney General's
office they said there was absolutely
nothing they could do because there was
no timelines in the law that would
require them to take action so they
could wait five years and then say no or
five years and say yes the law had no
obligations in it for timeliness and so
that's why the that's why this came
forward is again the Attorney General
said they could do nothing because the
law had no timelines built into it so so
the the women Squam could still have
uh well if there was a timeline place
they could still just um not accept the
uh the offer from the charter school and
that would have been okay that would
have been fine again it's just an
obligation to act and it was you know
this is no different than you submitting
a zoning permit someone just sitting on
it right and not acting on it right we
put zoning permitting laws in place and
we put timelines in place on zoning
permits for that very reason is because
you don't want municipalities or public
entities just sitting and not acting and
and not taking action so
um that's why this that's what this is
for so so just in terms of a possible
coming to a place that that that
addresses that that timeliness concern
um if um if we were to go with with d uh
including the within 60 days of
receiving the offer engages substantial
good faith negotiations for the purpose
uh for the purchase or lease of the
unused facility and then hard stuff
there
that would certainly provide the um the
the timeline
so again the the problem isn't literally
one of the conversations that came up in
in the in the disposal of this property
was why we want another school that's
going to compete with us in our district
so school work and knee-jerk react and
say no regardless whether the offer was
a fair market Price which would be in
the best interest of the taxpayers but
they could still say no right but why
would they do that so the idea is that
they entered into negotiations if they
can't come to an agreement then you go
get a fair market evaluation of the
property and which is in the best
interest of the taxpayer of the district
not in the best interest maybe into the
school but of the taxpayers the best
interest to get the fair market value
price of a given public piece of public
property and sell it for that fair
um right I you know I think there's
there's certainly statutes that that are
on the books now with respect to to the
the the sale of of public-owned publicly
owned land and buildings
um I I think it applies mostly to
um municipalities and not so much um
school districts but but at the same
time I think school districts Who had
who have that have made a decision to um
to uh dispose of a a piece of property
would likely be interested in doing that
I mean I don't think there's a lot of
school districts that that that you know
that that want to see something like
that sit so so just in the in the case
of the the windswam uh situation it did
resolve it took would you say nine
months for it to resolve uh the language
that you've got in the first part of D
um brings that down to 60 days and uh
and if they can't come to agreement it
doesn't mean negotiation stop you know
it could things could still happen but
but I don't think having something in
the law that um
that that puts it in the hands of puts
real estate transfer from a from a from
a taxpayer owned public entity to a to a
private entity putting that in the hands
of the uh the commissioner of education
is uh is anywhere close to the best
interests of of taxpayers
so again if I may Mr chair yes so again
it doesn't put it in the hands of the
taxpayer hands of the commission the
commissioner just establishes a a real
estate transaction like you would do if
you're assemble your house to get comps
you would go get what the fair market
value of a house is is listed at from
your realtor would look at comps in the
area the idea behind here is that we'd
have an impartial person doing an
appraisal then finding out the fair
market value and then offering that fair
market value as the price of the charter
school again which would be in the best
interest of this taxpayer of the
district
maybe so but not necessarily well the
bill clearly states that you know if
they aren't able to come to compromise
Sarah is the commissioner engages a
mediator so it's not putting in the
hands of the commission or the he's
handing it off to mediator X over here
to resolve this issue as we do in
negotiations
right but but but it this you know the
this this does bind the the taxpayers
though and so if if the mediator who's
who has been uh selected by the
commissioner comes back and says you
know what
um uh we think fair market value for
this property is a dollar
um uh the taxpayers would be obligated
then under this stat under this proposal
to sell it to the um to the pro to a
private entity for a dollar that's what
this is saying and it reverse is true
they could also come and say it's worth
100 million dollars and so no no but the
reverse isn't true because it does not
compel the private organization to buy
the private the the the decision this is
very one-sided the private organization
can accept or reject but the taxpayers
are you trying to speak or or represent
dry well flip a coin represent paternal
first and then represent Drive
thank you Mr chair
um Senator Lang question for you during
the nine months who was responsible for
the maintenance and upkeep of that
building was it the taxpayers the school
district who was taking care of it
according to our records of taxpayers
end up paying 210 000 in maintenance and
costs for that building while it was
under it could have been sold and we
wouldn't have had that expense but
that's what it costs to maintain and
thank you Mr chairman the idea of
selling this property from a
taxpayers to a 501c3 is already in the
statute it's not a new idea all we're
doing is putting the time limits on and
if we go a little bit further in 194
61 that the the
Roman numeral five Charter School
actually has a six months time limit put
on it but the school does not have a
time limit put on its side of it and uh
and in Roman numeral four in the right
of first refusal negotiations with the
Charter Public School it should be the
option of the offering School District
whether to sell or lease the property
under consideration at fair market value
I think that that this just kind of
equals the playing field do you agree
Senator Lang
I do again I think this is
um you can't the school can't force a
price on it on a charter school and make
them take it because they may not be
able to afford the price right so that's
the reason you do the fair market
evaluation and decide what the price is
and then this charter school has to
decide whether it can afford the
mortgage or whatever the loan it's going
to take to pay for that and if it can't
then it turns down the offer and says
thank you or they enter the negotiation
say we can give it from you this and go
into negotiations
um then the it's up to the school
district whether it wants to do it or
not but the fair market Price has been
set and so
um again I think this does equal playing
field and allows the school at the end
who has to write the check every month
for the cost of the school to make the
decision on whether or not to buy it or
not
thank you Mr chair just one comment
under RSA 194 colon 61 Roman numeral 4
to complete what representative Drive
was speaking about it says
um the chartered Public's the offering
School District whether has the option
of selling or leasing the property under
consideration at fair market value or
less so selling a building for a dollar
again I I don't think that anything in
here
um
stops the school district from lowering
the price if they wanted they get a fair
if they go to a mediation they get a
fair market value price and they go look
we'll give it to you for five million
dollars less million dollar lesser 100
000 less Nothing Stops a school district
from doing that with the charter school
I want to remind it while we're making
all these points about 501c whatever
remember it's a public school transfer
to a public school transfer public
students attend that school
let me just sharpen real quick sorry I'm
going to say anything Sarah Lang and I
have discussed this at length and I
didn't really want to say anything but
so my major issue with this amendment
was pretty much the last sentence it
says offering Charter Public School tour
accept or reject it is giving that
chartered school all the power in this
negotiation I'm not sure another
transaction
works like this any transaction in life
works like this where the buyer gets to
decide everything
so they get to accept or reject the
offer not that selling school gets to
accept or reject the offer of that
chartered Public School accepts or
who had their hand up first
and Luna thanks Mr chair so um so how's
this and I agree with what Senator
Fenton just uh just said I mean if if we
wanted to include language
um and eliminate that that last part
that puts all of the control in the
charter you know we could probably
probably live with that but but my
question to you Mr chair in terms of the
process here the the house position is
the the bill without the amendment
um the Senate position is the bill with
the amendment
um the common part of both those
positions are the bill is introduced
um and not the amendment is that a
possibility here in terms of supporting
the house position well there's always a
possibility that you know the committee
can come on say we support the house
version or or or or or vice versa seed
to the Senate version maybe even a seed
as the maybe amended but uh yeah there's
all there's possibilities however
um
but but I guess what I guess what my
question is
um as um as uh you know representative
Myler uh is is likely to be removed from
the last committee conference because of
his inability to support the house
position
um I'm supporting the house position and
I want to make sure that I'm not going
to be able to be replaced because I 100
percent support the house position
I think what we're looking at in the
first bill with the the house would be a
seating to the amendment amending the
Senate version
so right but I'm saying we weren't
supporting the house version
no no we weren't supporting in the first
bill but but the the 275 the first bill
was house is house position right now
and and representative Myler could not
support even of even a a minor change on
that so he he would be removed from the
committee for not being able to support
the house position I'm saying what would
happen in in this case where I'm 100
supportive of the house position
it we're not talking about that we're
talking about the Senate version right
now right it sounds to me like you're
looking to be removed well I'm I'm what
I'm what I'm interested in in doing is
is is asking
um um Senator Lang uh whether or not
there's some common ground we can we can
um we can come to and I think I think
Senator Fenton laid out that Common
Ground could probably be the bill is
introduced plus the Senate Amendment
right up to the last sentence and just
you're saying taking out the portion of
deals with leasing I'm saying taking out
because that last sentence deals with
lease and that's how many years
like in Washington DC it's the it's the
taking out taking out the sentence that
that um that puts the um the buying
party in the position to accept or
reject and the selling party which in
this case is the taxpayers don't have
any control over
um uh you know
or that if we were to eliminate that
does that get us to a common I
understand you're saying yeah Mr chair
if I may yeah it just deals with
um
the the verbiage saying uh for the
offering chartered public school to
agree to or reject
so what we're looking at is the
appraised values how to determine a fair
market price for the offering Charter
Public School get rid of to agree to or
reject and in the last sentence again to
so I understand what representative luno
saying I think Senator Lang and I have
had this conversation as well would that
could we take a break for a couple
are we doing house senate break we're
taking a break for the the we need to
think through this yeah okay
okay yeah
okay we'd like to go ahead here and
continue with uh uh the Community
Conference on this bill
um
appears that we
on the house side we're good with taking
out the words on the fourth line from
the bottom to agree or reject and the
bottom line to accept or reject and to
make Amendment with those out
good so so what what uh the you know so
we will then take a vote first of the to
a seed to the Senate version as amended
by the committee here to take out those
words I just mentioned
object so I already asked this question
again whether we needed a piece of paper
in front of us with the actual amendment
number and she said no no so if it's a
simple Amendment like striking these
five words in two locations we can agree
to that we can vote on that and the
committee report will be drafted in such
a way that'll reflect it yeah
so we'll take a vote from on on the
outside first separate from
so I'd like to see a raise of hands for
those that are in support of the uh
change that we just allude to take out
the words to agree to or reject online
fourth line up
to accept or reject on the bottom line
out also all those in favor
all three of you are good too so looks
like we have a
a completed committee a conference here
with we're receding to the Senate
version as amended
and Jen would you take care of getting
this amendment thank you
that's very very good that I appreciate
it that's good work
questions
all the signing has to be done
by thirsty
yeah and then you go over and you look
at it and you sign it look inside or
else you can have somebody sign for you
yeah speaker
yeah yeah yeah or or the your your boss
anything else on it thank you very much
everybody we're done
foreign
okay we are back in uh
HB 275 and act relative to schools
approved for our school tuition program
by a school board on the community
conference is now open again and uh we
are prepared to move forward here with
our recommendation and the
recommendation is to
concur
with the Senate version as amended
and
or no we're going to concur with the
amendment
so the amendment Mr chair I may the
amendment is if you're looking at the
bill on line 15 we're going to strike
the words complying with the provisions
of RSA 194 colon 23-e whatever that's
yeah I'm going to strike those words out
and leave the rest of the bill as is
that would be the proposed amendment and
and we did have an amendment on the
table in front of us which was 2192h
yeah and if we look at line 15 we're
taking everything between the words
applying and the RSA reference numbers
out
so it'll read is a public school or
okay so from the house side
all those in favor of language that I
just read
say I I said inside
so we have concurrence now on the
amending language
so we are amending the acceding to the
kind of version with this amending
language
[Music]
thank you very much this is the
committee of conference on House Bill
610 and I thank you all for being here
um this is was originally a bill passed
by the house in order to prevent
discrimination against different types
of providers for the therapeutic
cannabis program when it was initially
written
um there was I believe there was the
understanding that if you included
Physicians advanced practice nurses and
Physicians with assistance you covered
all of the providers in the state that
are able to prescribe controlled
substances in the state unfortunately we
have four different professions
podiatrists dentists
naturopaths and optometrists who are not
included in those statutes but do
prescribe controlled drugs the original
bill in section one would allow any
Doctor Who anybody in the state who is
allowed to prescribe drugs to humans and
is approved through the DEA prescribing
process in order to write the
certification for cannabis uh the reason
this is important we have 89 patients
with glaucoma on the program glaucoma
with elevated intraocular pressure that
leads to losing your vision and cannabis
is something that does address that not
one of those patients was certified by
their optometrist they had to go to
another provider because the
optometrists were not allowed in section
two there's another issue as well
there's generally the idea that all kids
see a pediatrician but we have a
shortage of Pediatricians we have some
kids who are going to Family Practice
providers who specialize in Pediatrics
but they are not pediatricians there are
also some kids that are so medically
complex that their pediatric doctors a
pediatric oncologist because frankly
they're trying to see their next
birthday the idea of requiring a
pediatrician when they sing another
specialist who already specializes in
Pediatrics doesn't really make much
sense in the practice and because this
is one of the areas where in our roles
and in our laws it says pediatrician but
but it's it's one of those areas where
we need to try and address this
um this bill then also had two in the
senate had two bail reform bills added
on to it one which is uh similar to
what's being seen in criminal justice
and uh that's section three and then
section four was an appropriation that
was not seen in criminal justice had
been put into the budget but um was in
talks to be in the budget I don't know
that entire process on the budget for
the million dollar appropriation for
electronic bail but right now it's all
on paper so if you're arrested in one
part of the state nobody knows unless
they know to call
um unless they know to call Chad Chester
because you were arrested there so it's
trying to address one of those flaws in
the program then finally sections five
and six
um are came from a different Senate Bill
180 the first section basically codifies
what's already happening with having the
oversight boards look at the labeling
and educational materials it's good to
be able to codify that the other is
addressing the hemp derived products
these come out of the 2018 Farm Bill
Bill wear hemp products under a certain
concentration of THC Delta 9 were made
legal because we need to have as an
industrial product that's what brought
CBD those two sections five and six are
also were also attached on House Bill
611 that bill is going to is calling to
a committee of conference Wednesday
morning and I think that that is a more
comprehensive look at all of cannabis
and looking at a council for cannabis
legalization so I believe that it'll be
a lot more appropriate to deal with
sections five and six in the committee
of conference for 611 and so I would
argue that we look to just strike that
today so that we can deal with that in
the more appropriate vehicle for Senate
bill for sections five and six
I guess my first question would be if
there's any concerns that people have
with the first two sections on the
therapeutic cannabis program to prevent
that provider discrimination and to
allow kids to be certified by the
Pediatric Specialists that they normally
see
so I know that that language is similar
in the house and the Senate versions
um thank you yes um representative Weber
said the language is similar it's
actually the exact same language in the
House and Senate it passed our committee
20-0 and it passed on consent
so that that section
um should not be I I don't see any
objections to that part so that's good
to see
um or would there be any objections to
moving sections five and six to House
Bill 611 and therefore striking what
we're doing today striking those from
today
um
first of all
former representative Canuck contacted
me over the weekend
there is a
um
RSA change that should be made
apparently
um oh yes he testified to that in front
of the Senate but inadvertently it
didn't happen it should be in section 2
and it first came to verse that could be
made as a non-rollability because it's
just directing the reference but if we
can get in there now that would be
better yes I think that'd be a good idea
to correct now if we're able to come to
an agreement so thank you for that
senator
foreign
so now we have the two sections on the
bail reform we have section three
um and that is an area where we have a
chairman Roy at the criminal justice
committee who has been dealing with bail
reform and I'm not sure if you could
give us a little bit more about the
house position on the bail reform on
thank you so
as far as the the house position
regarding section three
which is the um hold on a second that's
the portion regarding people held for
certain offenses
um the house the committee retained all
the bail bills from the house and the
Senate this year to come up with a
comprehensive bill that addressed all
the issues and there are many and the
first issue that was important actually
addresses section four which would be
the the million dollar appropriation
because all the other ones are
somewhat negatory because of the fact
that even if someone's held for a a
felony a violent felony to see the judge
on Monday that person could still be out
on bail from another jurisdiction and
that judge would not know there's no
system in this state currently for
judges or for police officers or for
bail Commissioners to know who is on
bail until the paperwork from the first
arrest gets back to the court
so
we realize and that's I discovered that
by starting to look into all these bail
bills to get to the bottom of what the
real problem is based on the the makeup
of the house everything we do out of
necessity and deference to the message
we got from our voters is work together
in a bipartisan fashion to come up with
a solution
um and that's and that's where we are
and why we decided to retain them all
and work on them together both sides of
the aisle over the summer to come up
with a piece of legislation that would
be taken up first thing in the fall
that would address all these issues so
that's where we're at
thank you
I think only that that I uh I would say
that the both of the I realized that one
of the bill Provisions may be simpler
than the other but uh what I have heard
from people I've been speaking to is
that they very much want to keep
everything as a package so that it's all
on the table one very uh cohesive
package can be brought out and it
certainly sounded to me like there was a
very firm commitment to spend the time
that was needed and here's my thinking
on that it's something that really
requires the input of the stakeholders
of which there are many many with very
differing points of view so I would like
to see it all worked on in public in a
in a proper work session subcommittee
session so that it can be
thank you
um Madam chair
this issue has been worked on for a
number of years now
I can sit here and I can tell you that
when this issue was brought
through the Senate
there was a lot of misrepresentation
about what this program was going to
look at and within months and I don't
mean five or six months I mean within
two to three months we started hearing
back from the stakeholder so people that
are directly affected by this our law
enforcement especially about the failure
of this program and we have tried over
and over and over again to reach a
solution
and every time there's always another
problem another problem another problem
we have tried
this bail reform that's here came out of
the Senate
I think it was 20 21-3
bipartisan because as the representative
said we've heard from the people to work
I don't know what else you can do here
just today in Manchester someone else
went and robbed store used a box cutter
was arrested
found out this was a person that was out
on bail and Senator Bradley can speak to
an issue that happened today in Nashua
same thing someone's out on bail
committing another crime
how many times does this have to happen
before this legislative body is going to
say we've had enough we're going to do
something about it because that's what
we're hearing from our constituents
we're hearing from not only our
constituents but we're hearing from law
enforcement we are hearing from mayors
of cities and on Senator Susie can speak
to that because the mayor of Manchester
came into our committee to testify in
support of this legislation they need
our help and they need our help and they
needed our help two years ago but quite
frankly we couldn't get out of our own
way because everyone wants to have
something to say and put their fingers
on it or do something and in the
meantime crime is flourishing out in our
communities and our constituents are
asking for our help now we have an
opportunity to do something this is very
clear about exactly
what is supposed to be happening
representative we took the language that
you wanted concerning the um the million
dollars to um to do this electronic
system so that there's better
communication
what else do we need to do here
how many times do we have to keep coming
to the house to say look we need to fix
this
and not keep running into a wall where
people say we don't want to touch this
we don't want this to move we want to
leave this in place but in the meantime
the police are complaining and our
constituents are complaining what else
needs to happen
we've looked at this this is the third
biennium
what else
what else do we need to do and let's see
if we can resolve it here and now so
that by the time we're finished at the
end of June our constituents are going
to know that their safety is being
respected and we've done something about
chairman
um sure um what else do we need to do
let's start with Okay so let's take
what's in here right now if you commit a
b or c you're held over for the judge
does it mandate the judge does it change
the standards that we're putting it by
bail reform as far as what the judge
does because if it doesn't it's he's
just all you're doing is holding them
for three more days the judge is still
going to follow the existing existing
mandate in the barrel form which is the
preference that they be released on
personal recognizance okay thank you
representative I I would look at
somebody by the Senate page two except
as provided under 597 c a colon c uh
excuse me one C A person who is charged
with homicide and it tells the judge
these are the people that are not going
to get bail reform we're not talking
about someone who gets arrested for
shoplifting or something like that
those are the ones that we've said okay
it's a non-violent crime these are
violent crimes where people are being
put back out on the street it's a
revolving door we need to stop the
revolving door so this I think gives a
lot of leeway to the judges about who's
coming out believe me if someone who's
committed an aggravated felonious sexual
assault should under no circumstance get
bail none
none
and if they do get fail
shouldn't they be answerable to somebody
for that
absolutely
so this is what we're looking at these
are violent defenses not non-violent
defenses which I think should be the
clear line when it comes to bail reform
as I said we're not talking about
shoplifting or some of these other small
little petty crimes I agree they should
not be held
because for some folks it makes a
difference whether or not they're going
to lose their job or they're going to
um you know they don't have enough money
to pay for their rent or food or their
family or pay for their honor me
automobile so they can go to work we're
talking about people that are committing
violent crimes
violent crimes that's what we're asking
of the house can you recognize that
these are violent crimes that are
committed against our fellow citizens in
the state of New Hampshire that they
should not get bail
none
um I I would I would I would agree uh
with several caveats first of all it's
incumbent upon us to recognize that
under our system of justice everyone is
innocent until proven guilty in the
court of law so there are accused of
violent crimes as part of that admit
deciding whether or not they should be
allowed bail or not should be a weight
of their of their um criminal record
of their um propensity for showing up to
court when they're supposed to where
they're from are they are they from out
of state they're not probably not going
to come back there's a lot of things
that go into that and I feel without
giving it
um more consideration and getting into
the details of things in the springing
up throwing out a blanket these people
are going to be held I just don't know
that it's going to it's going to solve
our issue and we'll be back here again
next year and say Well they're still
getting out because the judge says let
them go
well representative I'd like to put out
that they have to go in front of a judge
yes okay it's not a bail commissioner
it's a judge and if I remember correctly
last biennium we did have Provisions in
there concerning someone who had who's
been out on bail and who has broken the
law again that there were going to be
Provisions for them to be held but
unfortunately it died the house did not
agree
so
we try so what else do you what else do
you want what else what else do you want
in here that's not here that has not
been tried before
um thank you part of it too is it needs
to not just be what we here can agree to
it needs to be something that can be
agreed to by the house as a whole as
well and I don't know if there's other
viewpoints as well that you'd like to
I I don't think so I think I think
representative Roy has said pretty much
all of it I I will
remind people that
as much as this goes to judges
instead of bail Commissioners which is
better
uh the
accusations of Major Crimes
and incorrect accusations tends to fall
more on certain groups of our sitters
and raid than others
and that's always a concern and I know
it's been a concern of the house
throughout this process
but I I just would feel more comfortable
going with the other
with the other way of dealing with this
the the committee retained
the Senate bill in question for a reason
and I think that that is the house
position and I think that we should
defend it I think that we would have
significant problems getting these
Provisions through the house as a
committee of conference
recommendation
and and again we have to have a
significant concurrence on that to get
thank you for bringing some of the
viewpoints that we do have in the house
we do have the we do have the you have
more
um I I was just going to say that as as
to the last two Provisions
um
uh five and six which do not have to do
with with bail
um whether it goes on 611 or this bill I
I'm I'm neutral to I believe they're the
same Provisions so
um if if that's helpful to have them
here rather than somewhere else that's
not going to be a problem but it's it's
the bail issues that are and and the
discussions I've had with people are
basically that the bail Provisions are
are really a sticking point for the
people I've spoken to in the house
thank you um we actually did have uh
quite a few challenges even getting to a
committee of conference on this bill um
regarding the Bell reform language most
particularly in section three
um so heading back to the house with the
language that passed the Senate would be
an exercise in futility at best
um
I have a question around the section
four I know that we've had you know many
high-profile cases hit too far too close
to many of us I don't know um to what
impact we've had people who are out on
bail and one jurisdiction and not
recognized in another jurisdiction and
therefore released and going on for
other crimes do we have any information
as to how this would increase Public
Safety to have that appropriation if we
were able to get have that we I don't
see actually I guess my first question
is I don't see the side of the the part
of the negotiations agreeing to continue
with section three in the bill my
question I guess for the Senate would be
if there's any path forward to this bill
without Section 3 or not
could I have a caucus yes please yes a
foreign
uh thank you very much and thank you for
giving us the time for that caucus
section three is a complete sticking
point for the house it's not going to
pass it is it is written
um if we were if I'd like to know the
whether or not the Senate would be
amenable to discussion section 4 and the
rest of the bill without section three
um if that's the case we'd like to be
able to then come back and recess and
come to another day in order to better
discuss section four and making sure
that the legislators and the people and
most importantly all the Departments
involved in this have the information
and data so that they know who actually
is out on bail so that they're not
Flying Blind on a paper-based system
but in order to do that we'd need to
know whether or not Section 3 is a
must-have for the Senate so I'd like to
find out if Section 3 is a sticking
point and it's either section three or
nothing or if there's room for
negotiation
not likely
so let me just say a couple of things
about section four
because it was in hb2 and we pulled it
out
to put in this bill to try and
create something a little bit more
comprehensive it really needs an
appropriation of 750
000 dollars
for that apartment of safety and almost
a million dollars for the court system
to implement that that's the testimony
we got I have an amendment prepared
uh to do that if we choose to go forward
I think the problem that we're having
those of us that supported in 2018
the bill were promised by The Advocates
for the bill that violent criminals were
not going to be let out well that's
wrong that is patently wrong and
everybody in this room knows it's wrong
so the Senate has passed three separate
in three separate years bills two of
which have been mined in 21 and 22 and
then Senator Susie's in 23. and quite
frankly you guys haven't even tried to
pass it so we're frustrated
we thought we were getting
to some progress last year but
unfortunately in the committee of
conference we linked the three strikes
or no shows three strike no-shows to
what is a very surgical approach in
Senator Susie's bill
and we thought we had an agreement and
then turned out that the sponsor of that
didn't have the right language and it
was after the deadline for committee a
conference so
um
you know
the rest is history couldn't couldn't go
forward it
undermined the entire bill so
um
you know we sit here
we know it's a problem
we really know it's a problem we have
example after example I mean Senator
Carson talked about one I have one just
in the last couple of days
I think we would all agree that we need
to do everything possible
to protect people
in their homes on our streets from
violent crime and we're not doing it
quite frankly and we've seen the failure
despite the promises of the legislation
there was enacted in 2018 which
regrettably I have to say I voted for
because I was promised something that
hasn't happened that's why we're
frustrated that's why as far as I'm
concerned no is the answer no
negotiations unless Section 3 is in it
so here's what I'd suggest you have the
Senate leadership sitting here okay I'd
suggest you go back and talk with your
leadership both on the Republican side
and the Democratic side before you say
categorically which is your apparently
your excuse for not even willing to talk
about section three that it can't get
through the house
I would recommend you to that and we
come back in a couple of days
yeah yes I um first of all there's no
excuse for anything if you I suggest you
look at the vote record in the house and
you'll understand why we say it won't
pass the house
um if it was representative Roy here
today I'd probably agree with that I
might want a couple of the things in it
but it's not and I don't see the point
of replacing the Democrat members and
passing it just to see the thing go down
in flames in the house I just it's a
it's exercising futility so I'd love to
pass something but it we have to pass
something that will pass the whole body
so but I'm happy to go back and see what
we can do well and thank you for that
actually you bring up some really good
points that are part of why I'm
reluctant to move forward on this today
you we know that when Bell reform first
came through we were trying to address a
problem and we thought that that
legislation was going to address it
there were promises made that certain
things would happen but then the
legislation didn't follow through on
that I personally believe that we need
to have criminal the house criminal
justice committee come out with a
recommendation on what to do
or elsewhere in the possible situation
of seeing another unintended consequence
by putting something through that we
don't that we don't know all the pieces
on the board
um between the fact that we know that
the existing language does not have the
votes and the fact that we've already
committed by retaining every single bill
on this topic in order to bring forward
a comprehensive plan to address this and
make sure that while we're making sure
that violent criminals are off of the
streets we're also not accidentally
sweeping up other people who have been
accused of a crime but that accusation
is false or malicious it's it's a
delicate balance it's an absolutely
critical one it's I don't like seeing
any of these people released immediately
and then going on to commit and one or
two more crimes in the same day but we
also need to be careful that we don't in
reaction cause other problems either and
I do know that the basically the Mandate
of the house is that section 3 won't
pass so if that is the case
um
representative Weber
I would just add that although the vote
in the house to request a committee of
conference was uh 194 to 175.
um
that sounds overwhelmingly positive but
the discussions that I have had with
people are their desire to keep the
original 610 alive and for many house
members they were very disappointed that
a completely unrelated bill from an
unrelated committee was attached to a
simple uncomplicated and very beneficial
Bill and there was a lot of soul
searching before
uh on the part of the people who voted
against a committee of conference but
that was to keep the
Cannabis Provisions alive and I think
that
the vote would not be that close if it
was something else and and section three
specifically was a no-go
so I I don't want to waste people's time
if if section three
is the
if section three is what's needed
um I'm not entire I'm more than willing
to give this more time but I don't think
you're going to get a different result
I just wanted to say something because I
haven't up to this point but Section 3
is the language from my bill Senate Bill
252 and as the Senate President said on
numerous occasions
um this language similar language has
been considered in the Senate
um a couple thoughts number one is as we
talk about this section yes bail reform
talks about the individual that's been
accused innocent obviously until proven
guilty but none of this discussion ever
seems to recognize that
we've delineated certain crimes because
these are victims and there are people
on the other side and although we don't
have a significant tracking mechanism
which I hope we can get to I think we
can all agree to that in section four
um in the meantime
people who have been victimized are then
re-victimized because of a process that
we have that we have not had the
wherewithal to fix and that is my
frustration here now the fact that this
discussion is section three All or
Nothing is probably even more
infuriating if if you're willing to have
a conversation about the crimes that are
delineated and say the problem I have is
with you know the first one listed or
the last one listed I'm very happy to
entertain those conversations but these
were specifically selected because of
the impact on victims and the fact that
somebody who's accused of aggravated
felonious sexual assault can walk out of
a police station on PR bail before a
detective has even had the ability to
complete a report to get it to the bill
commissioner
that's on us and and that's not not the
right circumstance now this bill doesn't
purport to fix all of the problems they
complement chairman Roy on looking at
many of the others maybe it's the bail
Commissioners maybe it's the magistrates
I personally happen to think we need to
go to a magistrate assistant
but in the meantime people are being
victimized and I just can't in good
conscience say
oh well
um and it's the reason that I've been
here advocating for this provision of
the bill so as I said I'm I'm willing to
entertain a discussion about pieces of
it but to just say the whole thing is
gone
I'm just not ready to go there yet
representative
um thank you um
chairman and and thank you Senator
um you bring up a good point I I think
that um
to the um the Senate president's Point
into your point um we should take the
time go back speak to our respective
leadership
um I I'm willing to look at this and see
if there's something that we can do with
section three that would possibly pass
um the body of the house give it a shot
um as it stands as it's written it won't
um but we could massage it look at it
and see if there's something we can do
as a stop Gap until we can deal with the
comprehensive reform
um I'm totally open to doing that
so
I think what probably makes the most
sense now would be to recess until
tomorrow afternoon or when would be the
best time for people to
recessive then it would have to be after
3 45 because of the 24 hour notice so
um
does it have to be 24-hour notice if
we're recessing from a Time certain to
another time surgeon
that I don't know what's that
a break
so can we have a break and then
reconvene
um some point tomorrow or how would that
work I don't know the technicalities on
this
I think you can recess to a Time certain
yeah because some I mean you know in a
committee or conference sometimes a
recess for an hour recess for an hour or
two hours yeah so I don't think that's a
problem available later today if that's
helpful
um but I don't know what anybody else's
schedule is like I'm also free on the
20th but I want to make it clear that
um
everyone
negotiating these
various provisions of that
in this forum rather than in a forum
which would be a proper work session is
very problematical for many of us in the
house
foreign
so I I just uh had advice given that um
house rules now say that any recess
needs to wait 12 hours
um because of the time of day that we
have I would not
in other words you can't recess to go
take a break in Pockets if you
need to correct but because we won't be
coming back before 3 45 a.m We would be
safe to recess to tomorrow
um
would
I guess time frame wise we need to see
three all day tomorrow I personally
prefer to do it in the morning but okay
yeah
oh that's right
has to be after two
I
I can't do 3 30.
um I I can do as long as I'm I'm out of
here before or four with the time frame
so earlier in the day would be better
for me or Wednesday we could do that
I have we have a
other Committee of conference at 11. so
yeah and I know that
um representative Palmer is available
Wednesday tomorrow is booked okay okay
so it looks like uh tomorrow is book
solid
um
Wednesday
nine o'clock we
I believe I could make nine o'clock work
um
so that gives us
okay
it's hard enough okay so uh we will
sadly need to replace you but uh better
than to pull you away from work when
you're needed one question yes put your
microphone
as I was looking through the testimony
on um hb2 or SB 252
um there was
the a lot of different people had
contributed
and there was some question in my mind
after read it whether whether this this
language actually would
um solve the problem and so if I were
coming back what that I would you know
if there's if there's more evidence
I like I like evidence if there's more
evidence that this really would solve
the problem rather than something a
little more comprehensive I know you've
made very strong uh case for this
particular section but there was some
testimony that questioned whether this
would actually solve the problem that
we're talking about about keeping
violent people on the street
um so if there's any more information
available
so I just in response to that say that
over the last three years I think this
language has been refined to take the
most surgical approach to the most
egregious violent crimes and
um
folks like myself who support it but
then you know opponents of it the
surgical approach focusing on the most
violent crime seems to be something that
we ought to be able to unify around so
that's why
thank you thank you
Madam chair I'll make sure that the
amendment on the bail track or financing
is distributed thank you very much
thank you and with that we'll recess